a strong industrial base is a
prerequisite for sustainable economic
growth in Europe with these premise in
mind EU ministers meeting in the
competitiveness Council agreed on the
importance of systematically integrating
industrial competitiveness issues into
all policy areas from environment to
energy trade and regional policy
ministers also discussed the midterm
review of the Europe 2020 strategy for
growth and jobs which aims to draw
lessons from the first four years of the
strategy and assess whether it is still
an effective tool to poster growth and
jobs on Friday ministers assess the
progress made on the development of a
European research area a lot of progress
has been made but we do still have to go
the last mile and we must therefore
focus on a limited number of priorities
which we think would be to achieve a
transparent single homogeneous market
with the clear rules for a circulation
of researchers and then we should have a
joint programming between national and
european programming ministers agreed on
the importance of putting more money
into research and innovation as well as
increasing the efficiency and the
quality of current expenditures